hey folks Chris waters here with a
gamespot news update currently at best
buy and walmart the xbox one titanfall
bundles are selling for four hundred and
fifty dollars about fifty bucks off the
original four hundred ninety nine dollar
price point the deal went live today
although it's unclear how long it will
last if you've been considering an Xbox
one this is currently the best deal
around and technically it's cheaper than
a PlayStation 4 which retails for four
hundred dollars but doesn't include a
game other retailers like gamestop and
Amazon continue to sell the xbox one and
the xbox one titanfall bundle for full
price at both best buy and walmart
you'll need to add the console to your
online cart and proceed to checkout then
you'll need to sign in with your site
account or just use a guest account to
see the final price free shipping and
free store pickup delivery options are
available Walmart also currently offers
a starter bundle for the Xbox one that
includes the system and your choice of a
game for five hundred dollars but you're
just going to choose titanfall I mean
it's the best game on the system and if
you don't believe me just ask gamespot
com which is me also on gamespot
whatever I reviewed it it's it's
excellent titanfall guys